former Vice President Joe Biden leads a
new Iowa poll of potential 2020
Democratic candidates sources tell CBS
News he is preparing for a presidential
run one of the people he is talking to
about his plans is Senator Chris Coons
in 2010 the Delaware Democrat won the
seat Biden had vacated and only on CBS
this morning senator Coons joins us at
the table senator good morning good
morning
last week the vice president was
reportedly at 95% I know you recently
spoke with him is he moving closer to
100 he is moving closer he's someone who
I am confident he was going to run I'm
optimistic he's going to run it's
everything is being put in place but
that last decision which you know
understandably is a big decision and is
going to be well it's a simple and
positive message think about it from my
perspective the worst thing about
President Trump is that he sees
divisions in our country and he cracks
them open he exploit them for his own
personal and partisan advantage Joe
Biden is someone who sees the
differences in our country and inspires
us reminds us of the ways in which we've
overcome them in the past and will lift
us up I personally have witnessed him a
comforting and encouraging Americans who
suffered great loss he knows how to get
back up when knocked down and he's going
to restore our place in the world
respect for the presidency and
leadership by the president do you think
that he should run senator there's one
school of thought I've heard among some
Democrats that his time has passed he's
a little older and that maybe his time
would be better spent rallying around
someone who he really believes in since
there are so many candidates created
that way of thinking I've heard that
argument but frankly first there's
another person his age who's getting
tens of thousands of young excited
people in the last campaign he has more
experience he has more experience both
in the Senate and as vice president in
the executive and legislative than any
other candidate running arguably than
all other candidates combined and we
don't need someone who's doing
on-the-job training there's a serious
matter because it matter president
political experience and we've seen the
consequences having president Trump
someone who never served either in the
military or in elected office as our
president has had real and negative
consequences I was at the Munich
Security Conference a few weeks ago it
was obvious how much of a command of the
world stage Joe Biden would have as
president from day one I assume you're
talking about Bernie Sanders when you
talk about the other candidate who's
altered the fact that you won't mention
a colleague's name suggests Joe Biden is
running and your question though to
forget about age for a moment Joe Biden
represents an older-style way of
thinking about the way government works
in Washington he's a creature of the
Senate he talks about that Mike
Mansfield story everybody has a story
everybody in the Senate even your
biggest enemy is this sounds different
than that now a lot of people in the
Democratic Party believe that whoever
runs for president is going to have to
run not as a kind of lettuce reason
together but as somebody who's going to
bring it hard and tough to Republicans
and Joe Biden is not that kind of
Democrat that's right and we'll see
we'll see whether what it takes to win
in the States we lost last time is
someone who is a hammer and tongs
far-left Democrat where someone who
actually speaks to middle America who
connects with the struggles of average
daily working Americans and who comes
across as someone who is listening to
and cares about them what I've noticed
going around the country is that our
primary electorate wants to win more
than anything else more than they want
ideological purity and if we're gonna
win in Pennsylvania in Ohio in Michigan
in Wisconsin I think Joe Biden is
exactly the sort of candidate who
connects with the average American
because he doesn't talk about
Republicans as if they're evil and
horrible he will figure out a way to
lead us forward that's a political
argument for getting votes but what
about working in Washington as it exists
now in a world where you know to get
things through the Senate people would
argue that there are not willing
partners Republican are you do you guys
aren't willing to work with them and
vice versa
that seems locked in that's exactly
what's wrong about a badly broken Senate
and I think someone who understands sort
of what's the deal point how to move
something forward is more important for
us than someone who can just give a
great in prophetic speech but has
absolutely no idea how to pass
legislation Fortin questions first in
his confirmation hearing for attorney
general you pressed William Barr on how
he would handle the special counsel
Robert Muller's report when it was
completed have you seen or heard
anything since then from the new
Attorney General related to how that
report will be delivered and or shared
no do you believe it will be shared with
Congress I hope so
he did say that he
we'll lean as far towards transparency
as he thinks the law and Department
regulations allow him if he doesn't
fully release the report I know there
will be prompt actions by many of us in
Congress first you to press and then
possibly too soon to have that released
because I think it's essential I am
hopeful that Attorney General Barr
understands the consequences for the
country if it is covered and as a former
as a former law enforcement official do
you believe the sitting president can be
indicted you know that's a legal
question that I reach this morning but I
do think the odds that he will face
indictment once no longer president
given the actions underway in the
Southern District now in the state of
New York and in other districts I think
is steadily growing
you know people when are we gonna hear
this report I don't know exactly when
we're gonna hear this report I frankly I
I believe it is imminent okay all right
the gentleman's time has expired
thank you so much okay